the dominoes are already starting to  fall against newsmax and the  defamation lawsuits that they are facing  former dominion executive eric coomer  has already settled with newsmax the  terms of the settlement are not known  but newsmax had to issue a  huge retraction against the allegations  that they made against  eric coomer and this is very very common  in litigation often you will give a  better deal to the defendants who are  willing to settle early and  those funds can then be used to fund the  rest of the litigation and get the big  money items from the remaining  defendants  so at least in the eric coomer suit  newsmax gets out early  but there are a lot of defendants that  remain so we'll see them in court